so let me start by bringing you back in
time we are 30 years ago and the first
word processes and spreadsheets are
about to hit the market and the whole
economic world is bracing for the next
big productivity Revolution the promise
at the time was we'd all spend so much
less time writing drawing slides
Computing numbers on a calculator
and here we are 30 years later and the
promise has come true we all have so
much leure time on our hands and
personally I only work two days a
week of course I'm just kidding the
reality of what has happened 30 years
later is we don't work less we just
write much longer Word documents and our
PowerPoint decks have gone from six
slides to 50 slides and I say that as a
consultant also we engage in much more
complex decision- making because the
amount of data that we have to process
has just
exploded and why is that important today
well generative AI is coming and is
coming to be embedded in the core of our
organizations and the way we work and
that will be the next big productivity
Revolution so the question becomes how
do we set ourselves up to actually seize
this productivity
opportunity I'm a marketer I spent all
my career in marketing and also advising
marketing professionals now some say
marketing is the number one impacted
function out there so I'm saying the
productivity impact in marketing is as
high as
50% so that question of how can I seize
that productivity opportunity is super
high on my mind right now and I want to
make the case it should be super
important to you all as well as Business
Leaders but also as consumers
so what will happen to marketing well
marketing has traditionally been a super
right brained creative type of function
that means what means we have excelled
as marketers by tapping into the
emotional needs of our consumers coming
up with that perfect product that
perfect Innovation to meet that need and
also then cracking that great message
that will convert the consumer at the
right place in the right time
already in the past 15 years with
digital marketing and analytics
marketing has evolved from being only
right brain type of generate skills to a
few more specialized skill sets for
example digital marketing or marketing
technology but now the difference with
generative AI it is transforming the
core of marketing activities now in a
recent study that the Boston Consulting
Group conducted with Harvard we found
that Chad GPT in its current form
already improves the the right brain
performance of marketers by
40% imagine what that number will be in
a year or two from
now so what do you think marketers would
do with a day and a half of free time a
week more y go more family time do you
think companies would allow that or do
you think companies will just let large
chunks of the marketing function
go well I believe none of this is going
to happen
I think if we don't steer that
productivity Revolution very actively
marketers will invest this time in what
they do best more content and more
ideas now if you think of more contents
there is a super productive outcome for
all of us as consumers more content
actually means much more personalized
content now think of that email that
you're getting from your favorite brand
every
week imagine if that email was 100% Tor
to you means only images of people your
age and gender even to people wearing
t-shirts of your favorite rock band
every product relevant for you and even
a humanlike experience powered by a bot
that is certainly a productive
outcome but there is also a very
negative outcome for us consumers here
and that is content
overload how many of you already feel
chased by the same content over and over
again
online now imagine if that content
chasing you if that amount of content
chasing you just
explodes and imagine if that content
chasing you also all sounds the
same now why is that a risk generative
AI has been trained on existing content
and data because of that it reduces
Divergence of outcomes and that grand
Equalization of marketing is certainly
not a productive outcome
so what is the solve here well I believe
marketing but also every function out
there that is being impacted by this
productivity Revolution needs to grow a
left AI brain and grow one fast and also
identify and product its top right brain
Talent now you're going to ask me what
do you mean by growing a left AI brain
well I mean the function needs to
strategically resale and reorganize to
embed people that can build use and
diffuse predictive AI tools in the heart
of decision making I mean for marketing
building teams of marketing data
scientists marketing data Engineers that
build solutions that can be distributed
to all marketers to for example unpack
performance and predict outcomes
imagining marketing being able to
understand what audience creative
couples are really hitting it off in the
market or what product is working with
which consumer and why or how is the
marketing fun all
evolving I recently partnered with a
consumer goods company that did exactly
that they decided to grow a left AI
brain
Advantage we helped them build tools
that were diffused in the entire
organization that helped every marketer
predict for every marketing initiative
what was going to be the sales outcome
how would consumer Behavior is going to
be impacted on every channel and every
touch point and go deep in unpacking
execution insights to understand what
creative was working and why that
created a super virtuous feedback loop
in the entire organization it also took
building a team of 30 plus left AI brain
marketers that buil these tools
customized them but also in turn upskill
the entire organization to use
them
but the teams only a part of the puzzle
I see too many companies out there
embarking on this journey just training
their algorithms and models only on
their current content and data now if
you do that the risk for a brand is to
be trapped in your current territory
concretely imagine you're a brand that
is super strong with
Millennials there is nothing in data and
content existing on Millennials that
will help you to be successful with gen
Z and in turn if you're never successful
with Gen Z you will miss out on
important Innovations and trends that
will make you stronger with Millennials
so I advise every company out there
think outside of the box think outside
your direct ecosystem on who could be
super relevant data and content partners
for
you imagine your construction company
and you decide to Market to Architects
for the first time you have zero data on
Architects what do you do who has data
on Architects other construction
companies but they're direct competitors
so where do you go well you go outside
your ecosystem potentially for example
with financial institutions
insurances you can set up a Federated
model with them train out goes on that
that will in turn makes you much
stronger to Market to a new consumer
segment and so are you we done if you
have that if you have that data if you
have those skills are you done you have
that left AI brain Advantage well no
actually you are not if you do that
there is a risk you give all of your
right brain to generative Ai and in turn
run a real risk of losing that
Divergence losing that super strong
brand identity being trapped in that
grand Equalization of marketing I was
talking about a minute ago in the
Harvard study we conducted uh with the
Boston Consulting Group in Harvard we
found that when people over rely on
generative AI the the collective
Divergence of ideas drops by
40% concretely that means that new ideas
don't come to the surface it means that
true Innovation is being stifled so what
is the solve here well you need to
identify the true artists the true
differentiators the true innovators of
your function now if you've ever worked
in marketing you know who these people
are they are the ones that always
disagree with you now you take these
people and you need to strategically
resk them to use AI well for example to
be inspired by new ideas to be inspired
by new trends to also crack fast
prototypes to multiply their impact once
they've cracked a great idea but you
need to protect them and teach them from
using the AI to generate and originate
original ideas for that they have to use
their human brain to keep those human
juices flowing and that in turn will
protect the identity of your brand and
your differentiation in the
market so I want to close with an advice
for any marketer out there what are you
good
at are you super creative are you the
true innovator in the room well if you
are cultivate that that will be your
superpower do you like data are you
super rational are you super fact- based
then you should specialize you you
should grow Tech skills you should be
investing in predictive AI competencies
but right now every marketer out there
needs to choose their brain thank
you